oh there's a lot of finger-pointing
today blaming the president blaming
conservative populism blaming Steve
Bannon or maybe Mitch McConnell for the
fall of Roy Moore the truth is the race
had zero to do with substance and
everything to do with salacious
allegations in a deeply flawed candidate
and for those trying to use Moore's
defeat too damn conservative populism
remember the populist issues that Trump
won on were literally I don't think no
time when I peeked in on the election
did I hear any of them discuss not
immigration not trade not really tax
cuts not really D regulatory efforts
none of those things were ever really
debated in the Alabama race now a man
that many believed could run against
Doug Jones in 2020 said this on my radio
show today there was no policy
discussion in this election I mean there
was no substance to this there was no
discussion of comps policies or form or
policies or and they did everything I
could to make sure that Doug Jones
policies weren't discussed it was all
about scandal this was all about the
allegations against Moore and of course
his missteps the volatile nature of this
special election in Bama was a joke from
its inception now Luther strange could
have stayed in the seat until 2018 but
once that special election was announced
by the governor Mitch McConnell and his
PAC rushed in and they protected or
tried to protect strange rather than
just let the people Duke it out sort it
out probably would have been a better
path consultants for congressman mo
Brooks were reportedly warned that they
should not work against Luthor strange
reports are they were actually
threatened then there was the
hokey-pokey quality of the president's
involvement first the president put his
right leg in for strange and then he
took it out and then he kind of put it
in for more and then he did a robo call
but still the attempts to pin this I
think this whole loss on Trump or his
agenda certainly are just ridiculous
it's predictable now Alabama remains
Trump country everybody I know lives
there friends for 30 years like people
love Trump down
Alabama the voters there are some of the
most vocal anywhere on the issues that
got Trump elected immigration
enforcement lower taxes of course second
Amendment rights and the bottom line is
they just didn't like very more the man
by the way who lost the governorship
there twice and including coming in
fourth against Robert Bentley who was
not exactly a you know Ronald Reagan in
his in his personality or approach look
his Matt Drudge tweeted last night just
too much crazy and nerve-wracking times
there is a limit well I agree with them
and I think the pinball machine hit tilt
and Alabamans just wanted the game to
end wanted it over and also Trump didn't
win by being like Roy Moore remember
thinking back on the election he we just
what do you think look at Roy Moore you
look at Trump and their approach they
are very similar
Trump was all about making America great
again Roy Moore was kind of about making
Alabama grimace again now here's a
lesson for Republicans you cannot fight
everyone at once you just can't you
can't take on the Democrats the media
the entertainment industry and the
establishment of your party unless your
candidate
has the money and the bravado and the
media savvy to win that's what Trump did
but it's a rare skill set not many
people have it and that kind of hand
hand political combat demands candidates
who are fearless and they're unafraid to
do interviews a month before an election
and I don't mean with a 12 year old
reporter okay got to be of it if you're
afraid of Good Morning America you're
probably not gonna be able to beat your
Democratic counterpart and the other
takeaway by the way is the critical need
for Republicans to engage minority
voters especially in parts of the
country that are traditionally hostile
to the brand of the GOP think about it
in Alabama 30% of the electorate or
black voters surpassing turnout for
Obama and Hillary so the GOP needs to
reach out to this community and we said
this we've been saying this Frank
frankly since Trump was inaugurated keep
doing those kind of campaign style
events because we remember when he went
to that black church in Detroit during
the election you know the people there a
lot of them probably didn't really agree
with them maybe they didn't like him
that much but I'm telling you you show
up and you talk to voters and they end
up respecting you more they know that
you cared enough to show up just to hear
their concerns Republicans have to do
this across the country and then today
at the White House by the way the
president announced a black pastor to
talk about his tax plan and what it what
it can actually end up doing for the
black community this was good we
represent a cadre of many families
across the nation african-american
families urban communities and Families
all across need this now and it's time
for a change and it's time that we
recognize that our president is making
good on his promises now if I didn't see
that in the evening news tonight
the last thing the left ever wants to
see is a conservative preaching
law-and-order an economic opportunity
entrepreneurship to the African American
community going into those areas they
don't like that they want a monopoly on
the African American vote they've had it
for a long time but this my friends is
exactly what is needed and Alabama
reinforces that big league well I think
the president gets it though so let's
hope the Alabama race serves as a bit of
a wake-up call to the rest of the party
before the midterms and that's the angle